mecheri plage mois la boîte qui pue
attention on n'est pas à temps on compte
on fait un décompte te rends pas des
comptes sac à connaître la teneur
propres atteint il ya des gens du public
qui veulent partir cadet jean lévy multi
vas partir tout de suite
attention je vais attention et des sacs
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez à temps
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr la joie sur
les doigts
[Applaudissements]
partout
ça
et sortir
bah c'est une horreur j'en ai eu sur le
toit d'animaux mention scène d'horreur
ce caucus sur le plateau mais si vous
pouvez partir évacuer plateau si vous
voulez évacuer le plateau
belle et jeune parti et les mecs intrus
qui assume verdez il a le plus grand des
plus beaux du gauche malouda franchement
merci série khatami les parties donc un
tiers ils font ce choix de ma part mais
je veux le faire de la lèche eris et une
infection
merci que la pâle max lapierre était
d'accord merci les séries
[Musique]